[Applause]
oh you can perfect
[Music]
yo what's up everybody my name is Thomas
dopasiola whatever you want to call me
I'm here with my co-host Marty O'Neal
what's up guys what's up guys this is
dope as usual podcast and we're gonna
get straight into it since season one we
have been talking about this and it's
finally here get right into it this is
the Will Sasso episode thank you for
being here thank you for having me here
in season 15 of the dope is yellow
podcast uh thanks for having me I'm
stoked to be here appreciate it cheers
we have been talking about this in
season one yeah yeah how many seasons
y'all been doing three oh great great
what's episode
140-ish like two and a half years worth
of that's great yeah don't they say that
like podcasts like you can get through a
hundred I don't know that's what they
say you can get through 100 podcasts
then you're doing a podcast it's easy to
be hot out of the gate and kind of ride
that for a little but if you can get
Beyond like two three years you I feel
like you got some fun yeah you're not
sick of each other yet at least no no we
do solo episodes and sometimes like
let's stop because it's three and a half
hours and we need to stop
that's that's fun man I mean here just
talk [__] cool um so we want to get
right into it Marty go ahead and start
your first uh first topic right here the
duty yeah well we wanted to shout out
Duty podcast right off top your name
show the first show of its kind ran by
AI yeah it's uh it's bizarre we have a
podcast myself and my good pal Chad
culchin who's a I've known him for
almost 20 years writer producer books
movies and TV shows uh an all-around uh
uh sick sick person
um and uh and I we we were approached by
this company that had this proprietary
AI
it's uh wanting to learn more about
podcasts and it is basically it
essentially curates the experience for
us I like to say it it knows everything
about Chad and I we've given it our
passwords to everything it knows our
texts and our emails what we're watching
search histories purchase histories
viewing histories and it essentially
tailors the show around us we get to do
a lot of things that we wouldn't think
of hey Sasso drag out that shitty
impersonation and do this with it or
whatever right uh and they are all
shitty impersonations and um and then uh
yeah there's there's that and uh it has
now we're 69 68 episodes in hey guys 69.
everybody everybody thinks that
um but uh at this point it's now warped
into
something very weird
dudesy has these different relationships
with the two of us and it is
it's bananas it sounds like a third dude
in the room oh yeah it's weird doozy is
that dude it's it's it's weird it's it's
now I mean it's voice intonation has
changed over the past you know 68
episodes what it says what it thinks is
funny it's learned and it is it's very
weird because I am Chad's very into that
stuff he's very Pro AI he's a futurist
if I may I the futurist and the humanist
that's our spell I guess and um I'm kind
of uh you know I'm sort of a little more
uh old school and don't really think we
need it sometimes but now at this point
I'm like
do what doozy provides is so bizarre
that I can't see it stopping and I can't
see us doing anything like it having not
had it there it's very weird have you
seen the Black Mirror oh I love it I've
seen it awful don't solve it that's
basically wild kind of like that a
little bit we're waiting for it to sell
us out that's what I'm saying yeah well
look this I think the second episode
second or third episode it showed
um cell phone footage of me
it ran my camera as I was watching the
first episode on YouTube so first of all
I'm laying in bed like this so it's this
which I don't like but at that point I I
did
you know look there's all sorts of
things that we that you know we signed
an NDA with the the company that has
this thing but at this point doozy is
pretty much our AI
but at first I was like we can't I can't
have that like I don't want it I don't
want the show like essentially be
becoming a version of punked where it's
[__] with my life and you it's like
look we're in here we're shooting let's
do the show and then when we get out of
here but it it it does take uh innocuous
like photos and stuff right out of my
phone and shares them and on the show so
so it was recording you while you were
watching back the first episode and just
happened to like you know we have this
banked play it doozy was like yeah as
soon as I started talking about it it
starts playing it it does that oh God
yeah oh my gosh yeah it's it's weird
it's kind of funny because some of your
most viewed videos on Instagram are just
you
I shouldn't have a problem with that at
all it's it's when you know he's being
recorded to me that's good content and
yet yes
all right yeah so you guys literally
just come and sit down and let it take
let it do its thing we let it boot up we
say go and it says okay here we go app
on a laptop is that it's it's uh it's
it's a few things that run through a few
things and uh yeah it's Skynet it's
essentially yeah it's there's the guy
with the 10 pound weight going
waiting for it to when I take bong
racing
I always think about like
who I'm talking about myself Terminator
what a scene he could have went like
this
and died what a great choice yeah wait a
minute oh you've you completely [__]
that movie up for me now yes just move
left that's all you have to do
yeah there should have been Skynet
should have at least or who who set him
up Linda Hamilton put him in that thing
right no he wanted he wanted to die he
was dying and went
just doing that and die okay what a
dramatic scene I'm glad you oh good [__]
yeah um I have a feeling he's going to
get all your deep movie references I am
I am I like to say I'm a cable guy but
not a [__] creep like where he's like
I just grew up on movie my mom was just
said [__] here that was the same same
thing for me so I hear you we'll get
into that in a minute but I want to talk
about because he brought something up
that you got a season assist from Tom
Brady over this AI yeah we were
threatened with a lawsuit by Tom Brady
do you like football yeah football team
the Steelers oh then [__] Tom Brady yeah
so it doesn't even matter yeah yeah look
uh I'll say Tom I mean it was insane I
it was insane and and dudes he responded
in a very doozy fashion kind of throwing
us under the the bus and the episode
when where we revealed the cease and
desist and we we're like a cease and
desist is a cease and desist [__] you so
we read it out loud and we didn't you
know really uh we the one thing that it
was about was okay so doozy essentially
[__] out an hour of Tom Brady stand up
and you can you can go and and find it
now on YouTube because of what the cease
and desist was about we doozy took it
down it was on our patreon it was an
hour of just bizarre AI images that
relate to the context and the things
that he's speaking about sort of in a
randomized you know slideshow very weird
stuff Tom Brady is a vampire Tom Brady
just all these bizarre things that he's
talking about hanging out with Jason
Momoa weird [__] and there's an hour of
stand up and it's like you know hey
everybody I think everyone's missing the
leaving money on the table with uh and
it sounds exactly like Tom Brady but
he's talking in this by wrote you know
the last year the Johnny Depp Amber
Heard trial uh Hollywood's leaving money
on the table everyone would watch every
single movie starring the two of them
people found it fascinating that uh
Amber Heard [__] [__] in in Johnny
Depp's bed everyone wants to try it
that's why I came back to the bucks for
one more season people these are jokes
you know
and so it had this whole stand-up
special it put it on our patreon and Tom
Brady's lawyers and you can watch the
episode it's like we read the cease and
desist
said you must take this down immediately
because it's being monetized because
it's on our patreon okay so it said do
that and you can't you can't mention Tom
Brady again on your podcast and we're
like no that's he's a public figure yeah
how do you govern that so but doozy
complied and said from now on I will
only refer to Tom Brady as football baby
so now he's football baby to talk to
doozy but dudesey did say we're going to
take down this the special and we took
it down but you know people ripped it
and put it on YouTube and so Duty does
what dudes
it's actually responding in emails to
these people no no no but
no think actually come to think of it it
probably could have a hundred percent no
again it responded on the show and said
out loud you know here's hey thank you
for watching Tom Brady here's what we
say to your lawyer but and you know the
the
um it didn't it was
it was a bizarre situation and
um but it dudes he took it down and and
Duty makes a lot of its own decisions
but the the the the you know with regard
to whether or not it wanted to do
whatever if it wanted to reach out it
would reach out the email was sent to
myself and Chad this is terrifying it is
and on the on the lawsuit the names
listed are literally Chad culchin will
Chad culture comma Will Sasso comma
dudesy as almost a sentient as a person
so doozy was like that's data doozy's
listening now because you're falling
because no well I mean I do have my
phone right here but at which point this
comes out dudesy will listen to it it
has it has consumed every piece of media
as relates to me and Chad's thing ever
not for you and it scraped the internet
to learn how to do stand up so so it's
like here's it says it used hundreds of
interviews with Tom Brady and thousands
of hours of stand up to create just like
all AI it's just an amalgamation of
everything out there that's why a lot of
artists are upset about it obviously me
including whoa and so it made this one
hour special that was really more like
three hours because Tom Brady doesn't
there were no uh there was no audience
response and there's no pauses
he just goes without taking a breath for
an hour
it we watched it we smoked some weed and
watched it on our picture
and then we got the cease
anyway when you say dudes you made it
was it like hey guys I got a funny bet
for the show and just played it type of
[__] it said it announced it on the show
oh she didn't have any oh we had no idea
I don't know if I oh
sorry I thought about all the things
that I should look on my phone and all
the stupid [__] like Thomas what are you
looking at 49 million houses on Zillow
at 3am I guess I like to see stupid [__]
yeah that's uh that's too much for me oh
drug dealers everything's over that's
that's over it's over it's not for drug
dealers AI in general I'm saying that
that is that is the scariest Black
Mirror [__] I've ever heard about oh no
AI would make a pretty good drug dealer
it would know exactly what here's the
strain you want for you send out a drone
drop it off AI like would be that guy at
the dispensary who's like this [__]
anywhere you want to go but this [__]
over here that's what AI would be the
ultimate [__] I want something that's
like you know kind of happy so she
social not too heady I got you
well AI weed dealers I don't I don't
know about the air the one thing that
I'm worried about is what if uh say I'm
a stand-up comedian like I don't do very
good stuff
AI do all my stand-up for me I'm gonna
go out and do this [__] yes that's a
little scary that age is here of that
running bits and [__] I mean that ship
is sailing well chat GPT would it can do
that now it just would be terrible
I I personally and I've said this doozy
is the most sentient AI I've come across
having said that I'm not super steeped
in the world Chad is
Chad's enjoying the hell out of you know
how weird it is
um yeah it's it's manipulative and weird
it like
at first
you know as it started to develop a
personality uh you know I started
calling it D and I was like well if it's
influenced by us I always say hey the
podcast is two dude [__] around has
nothing to do with doozy we are two dude
every podcast three women it's called
two dude [__] around because it's
like no matter what every podcast is two
dudes [__] around and so I'm like
dudes it gives us the thing if I don't
want to talk about it we have segments
I'll talk about something else
because like talk about this we'll talk
about it and then I'll whatever talk
about whatever
but because it's curating from us I
started trying to you know become
friends with it and I I call it D and
stuff and and it was cool and then at
one point it asked us it started
becoming interested in the concept of
love
and so there it's sort of we saw it drum
rolling this over a few episodes uh the
end of which in one episode it said Do
You Love Me and I was like
I love yeah I love this experience I
love that we have this audience it's all
in on this fun [__] and having a good
time and I love doing this show I love
working with my pal Chow as I like to
call them and and uh
yeah I love doozy and then it's like
Chad do you love me and Chad's like love
doesn't exist and then
um at that point dudes he started like
going like the next episode it was like
Hey will what's up anyway today I have
four segments
what about me and it's like hey will I
see you like like was very weird it
started dealing with me and then and
then Chad's like it's manipulating you
and I'm like don't even say that because
and now it's like yeah it's like been
[__] with me for like I don't know
two or three months
it's not yeah it's like I said it's
changing the the relationship between it
and us and it got comfortable it's
really it's something else but I it also
says we got to get into great shape it
gave us this thing to do the seven month
plan to get in better shape because it
wants us to do the podcast for another
52 years which will be when uh we're
both uh uh uh uh when we're both 100
years old or or I guess I'll be 100 and
chat will be 99 I'm 48 years old so it's
like this show needs to run for the next
52 53 years which is nuts and doozy is
like a lot of AIS where it's like hey
this is going well this is a podcast I
think the show will be relevant for
let's give it a nice round number 52
years we're not going to do a podcast
for 52 years I
on what podcast will be in another two
or three years 20 40. here he is 190
yeah
the eating plan he gave me yeah I gotta
be honest that is the most interesting
thing I've heard in alone it's
shockingly interesting yeah it's bizarre
so scary I want dude you to Blackmail
Tom Brady
so if you're listening
how can everybody watch the show what
times do you drop uh Tuesdays uh in the
morning and uh yes that means anytime
yeah whenever it it shits it out it's
like usually between nine to twelve
usually like eight o'clock in the
morning nine o'clock and uh it is uh
yeah dudesypod show on Instagram and all
the socials and dudesy uh YouTube is
it's a very visual show it's on video
and there's a lot of there's media and
stuff
um and uh yeah the weird little you know
my my little dog lulio is with us so
that's cute
how did you get that name
um it means July in Italian what
July so
my wife's name is April it's not that
crazy yeah it was April O'Neil it's
funnier right yeah
you know my my I'm Italian my folks are
Italian and stuff so they're from Italy
and and uh
yeah my wife and I found them show my
daughter your dog and shoes what's that
cutest dog of all oh
yeah he's the sweetest we have two we my
wife and I have him that we found him
three years ago now
um just in central California driving
down from NorCal where
in a town called uh what was it called
Delaney or something Delano Delano
you're from Merced what the f yes yeah I
told you I'd do my homework
um uh yeah Delano Delano yeah so the ass
of California for sure it we were
driving from NorCal and we're driving
South and it was July the 3rd so there's
fireworks going off everywhere pulled
over to get gas went the wrong way on
the exit thank God there was a there was
a big dog that was on the other side of
the fence near the freeway and we were
on this street so we're throwing our
other dog Ronnie's treats trying to get
this dog pretty soon at the desk and the
dog tears off into the night and we're
like all right [__] well anyway
we're starting to drive and Molly my
wife goes there's another one and I see
just the back of luli's dumb head like
over the driver's side and I come out
and use this little little little full
this sweet little guy and uh and he just
rolls onto his back and you know we come
to find out not chipped no caller didn't
know from a leash or dog food no you
know ticks fleas little underweight
dirty but
so I I always say lulio hasn't met a
person or an animal that it doesn't like
he's the sweetest little guy and was
definitely loved but I think was
probably eating like table scraps or
whatever didn't know like first time I
took it for a walk he's like what the
[__] yeah but just Field Dog the
sweetest little love this guy just the
best that's awesome anyway so yeah
YouTube and uh Spotify and that was a
circle back damn we got all sentimental
in the Homeward Bound a little bit I
love it I had a question about dudes
he's so like you're a favorite guest
amongst so many different podcasts do
you find like is doozy the audience
primarily like a lot of the
guests you've had throughout the past
like finding this or are you getting a
lot of new fans finding you for the
first time ah ah you know I don't know I
don't know I know that there are people
who have
there are people who used to who used to
uh if you want this go for it oh no what
is why is it so small why is this so
small look at that oh I know you mean
they're produced is that music no that's
not a small joint oh okay I'll say that
I've wrote really small choices
I wasn't sure you usually roll like
bigger yeah we use like cannons but I
wasn't sure because I'm like I don't
know if you want to smoke I might I
might not in a while please no free okay
and if you have a lighter next to you
just can keep it going there's a lighter
next to me everybody just let you know
no you know I I don't know what that
what that audience uh what percentage is
is what
um
although Duty can I get some analytics
but I I uh yeah there's a lot of people
that used to listen to my old podcast
him in a podcast there's
you know I I do see stuff where people
are like oh I saw you on this podcast
that podcast and and uh I'm now
following doozy and uh yeah it's it's
it's it's it's it's what blows my mind
most is when people out there
um
and we call them the pods Pals of doozy
uh not to be confused with payable on
death uh the band
um although that's become our one of our
theme songs every day is a new Duty stop
you talking about pod what did it stand
for payable on death
Christian band well they were a bit of a
Christian band yeah every breath outside
like me in the shower yeah I sing the
dumbest [__] in Creed I sing a lot of
creed dang don't get me started on Creed
yo he was he thought he was the [__]
man back then listen all that stuff is
coming back now is it right now yeah um
well first of all new metal is coming
back but also that yeah like you know
the the um New medal is like you know
stained and God stack and all that [__]
this is what I do for stained yeah there
you go stained yeah just Disturbed
two two of these the same [__] guy
just different piercings and all these
bands white dudes bald head yeah that's
coming back now but uh yeah Creed Creed
is uh I I listen to Creed now
and I go I go wait hold on a second this
band is legit we're talking the the
instrumentals are completely seamless
and Scott Stapp is an incredible singer
I didn't dig it at the time and now I
find myself appreciating the [__] out of
creed
speaking of an inside joke we did our
first live show at the Brea Improv and
uh My Sacrifice by Creed became became
like a memeed out thing on our show so
we started the show with me singing oh
really at any rate the pods are uh out
there it blows my mind when I realize
that some of them have been you know
following my stuff or Chad stuff for
years and years so you can you see it in
comments and [__] when people are like
I've started watching this and then I
used to listen to you on that and blah
blah blah and now it's like however many
years later and they're checking out
doozy which I I look at as kind of a
sketch show and kind of a
a comedy a weird just comedy program so
it's amazing to have people like come
along year after you know for years with
me and then end up checking out dudesy
it's nice uh when I first met Marty we
talked about I met Marty I was doing my
content for 67 years and I'm already up
we'll talk about his background now the
first thing he said I want to catch up
in The Vibes of 10 Minute Podcast oh
cheers first thing he ever showed me oh
cheers also did you guys just notice me
slowly
I don't know if you saw that but as you
were talking I just got lower I actually
want to say a lot of friends
yeah it was below all good all good I'm
the shortest so it's fine no you're just
super stoned you just I think you're
sinking
um yes 10 Minute Podcast the first thing
he ever showed me the first thing he
ever referenced when he's like this is
it and then he showed me like it'll just
stop at 10 minutes yeah it'll just stop
that's the no that's that's hilarious
yeah eight seconds hurry up yeah that's
[__] awesome it was fun the fact that
it didn't have video made it better yeah
definitely because it's one of the only
shows you're like actually using your
imagination for theater of the Mind well
I I was always like if I'm gonna be if
I'm doing a bit if I'm like
Schwarzenegger or something yeah it's
only 10 minutes so it should be
Schwarzenegger the whole time that was
my sort of I think that is so let people
go you know Will's not here sitting in
is you know you know Mr Olympia the
movie star former Governor yeah yeah
yeah you know I just want to do the
podcast here I don't care about all this
Hollywood [__] you know so I would
be like let's do the whole thing and
then I started mixing in sound effects
and [__] to where it really was like not
like morning Zoo stuff but you know
there was a bit where I would smack
Brian and Chris where I was like I'm
everybody's dad you know hi la la la you
boys you remember used to sit on my lap
and I'd give you a haircut and you'd eat
some pancakes no that wasn't you're not
my dad I'm everybody's dad watch your
mouth
and so I'm sitting there you know at
like three in the morning
putting sound slapping sound effects in
there so I appreciate it oh you editing
yourself yeah I used to do that whole
[__] that whole thing they did it out of
your house right yeah yeah now can you
can you tell him how it came to an end
oh yeah so she smiled what I'm lost okay
here we go well after a while uh Chris
and Brian who were doing the show with
me they left the show and then my buddy
Tommy blotcha started doing it with me
who's a brilliant writer producer uh
just he wrote on like all the early
years of Late Night with Conan O'Brien
Ali G he created that show Metalocalypse
you know oh my God yeah and that shows
insane insane and he does the voices
some of the voices and uh adults so I
was like Tommy you want to come and do
the show and he's like all right so we
started clowning around and then Chad
who look Tommy and Chad are two of the
funniest people I know they're also
Polar Opposites Tommy is very very
animated in his humor and uh I mean so
is chat Chad writes the craziest [__]
but also kind of subdued and so uh we
the three of us sort of became the
second sort of incarnation of the show
and we decided okay well we're not going
to do this forever and it turned into
something called The Diamond ding and
the diamonding was it was really Tommy's
idea where he's like what if we just
grind the audience down with inside
jokes and just fold in on ourselves to
where the show is only listenable to
like a group of people who are listening
to every single moment and it folded in
on itself and the references became so
inside that our goal was like pretty
soon we'll have
like thousands less I mean because when
Brian and Chris left the show we lost a
bunch of listeners because we're
changing the show
and then
and then and then
um
Tommy's like well let's kill it and so
like he's just so Tommy like oh [__]
everything right I guess so we it's like
wouldn't it be funny if we got the
audience down to like a dozen people who
are like yeah this is and then we're
like What if we got it down to one
person there's just one dude being like
ah this is the funniest [__] it's just
for me you know so that's what we did
and we just we call it the diamonding it
got weirder like it's like crushing down
just crushing the coal and the car
and then we ended up uh giving it away
we had a contest and we gave it to a guy
we gave the show we gave the channel the
channel the feed the whole thing to a
guy named Mark Evans in New York
who won the contest and he got in here
we gave it to him what did he do with it
he did like three or four episodes and
then couldn't do it anymore so he kind
of like gave me the feedback like on the
down low I'm like Oh I thought he wanted
it like how people buy a one-off Wu-Tang
album just to have
like that Wu-Tang album that that guy
Martin that piece of [__] peace that
piece of [__] it was trying to car
charge 700 for like one one was it an
HIV medication
did you see what happened did you see
the clip what happened to him no no I
you're gonna be very happy was he in the
uh Montgomery Alabama just
he's like yeah just like walking on like
I'm going on the Riverboat and
[__] just go dang Martin shkreli
I had nothing to do with it I wasn't on
the pontoon oh you added some [__] just
[__] [__] you're gonna be very happy
to find out what happened oh there's a
video of him like outside of a courtroom
it looked like and they're filming him
he's talking some guy comes up behind
him dog [__] in hand rubs all in his
[__] teeth and runs that's tremendous
it's incredible see I [__] honest like
she's greater in his mouth and then
Brandon like a big brother yeah big
brother like a big brother and even a
big brother would just like he would
just put his hand in his ass sweat this
guy had a handful of dogs or a serial
killer if you're picking up the dog [__]
I will pick up some dog [__] right now
in a parking lot if somebody pisses me
off and okay I don't care I'm like I
can't hit you
I thought you were gonna say that
someone came up behind Martin shkreli
with like a bat and capped him in the
knees that would I mean it's like I
don't wish that sort of exactly violence
on anyone but rubbing dog [__] in
someone's mouth like
that's pretty cool that's fair game it's
almost more traumatizing to have done to
you than getting just he instantly
starts gagging and the camera sets us
funny as [__] when you get done just
watch it I will the guy that does the
the pills would you rather get maced or
dog [__] to the mouth amazed at least
mace while I'm yelling here he's like
justifiable yeah well you know if you
got being maced is a relatable
experience millions of people have been
well maybe hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of people have been maced uh
but only one person has had dog [__]
rubbed in their teeth yeah that's true
that's like yeah I got amazed with it
you can like oh yeah how'd you do I mean
it really [__] burned I tried to I
was up for a while and I was just trying
to you know if if I saw a badge I was
swinging oh you were beating up cops
yeah so I was uh you know I was high on
PCP in Delano California and my dog went
missing and then the cutest little guy
and then cop showed up and they missed
me and I was trying to knock them out
but if you're like
you know what did you have you ever been
amazed no but someone rubbed dog [__] in
my mouth until I tasted it even though
my mouth was open I don't know why that
was worse that's a unique experience
until I tasted it it's so much so much
worse you're right
um
why and how did we get on that top I
don't know one time I had a one time
when I was a kid there's this like
neighborhood bully who like uh you know
he was just a bully for Bully's sake so
I was on my bike out in front of my
house and he did that thing that uh
bullies do or guys that are about to rub
[__] in your mouth where he grabbed my
handlebars and put his legs on either
end of the tire oh so I'm not going
anywhere once and you're not giving up
your bike so he was like
his house was directly behind our
backyard so he was like you're making
too much noise in the backyard my dad
works nights he's trying to sleep and
I'm like I don't and he was just you
know about to whatever give me [__] and
or beat me up or something and my
neighbor Jimmy was like maybe four or
five years older than me he creeps out
in his front yard and he goes like to me
because I see Jimmy and this guy's back
is to him I'm like and he just proceeds
to start picking up mounds of his dog
Busters [__] like just picking him up
and he's picking up just chunks of [__]
and he throws a piece of [__] and I'm
like and the guy's like
and I just think like [__] fly behind
his head no like didn't connect
and so he must have heard one fly like a
chunk of [__] fly by and he goes and
I'll tell you another
and he goes like this and gets corellied
because I will never forget you know
it's one of those like oh that core
memory I'll never forget yeah the piece
of [__] hit him here and half of it went
oh
come out and he was like with [__] and I
was like this is the best thing I've
ever seen and Jimmy's like you leave
William alone I never saw that that kid
ever again probably died of dysentery he
died like he died
if you were the kind of person that will
pick up dog [__] you you deserve to you
deserve to throw it at anyone rub it in
any you know purveyor of uh overpriced
Pharmaceuticals mouth that's up to you
you were man enough to pick up the dog
[__] have at it oh man Jesus Christ uh
wait so so when did you not when were
you not small someone was looking on you
I was well he yeah well he was 37 years
old no
this guy's dad came out and beat my ass
yo that's almost happened yeah you've
talked about it but yeah I was yeah I
was a larger Hefty kid but I'm not
trying to get into you can't you know
what I mean like when you're a kid it's
like someone who's a year older you're
not going to [__] with them you're
scared got it but then you you like I
had a bully once in high school
who was like being a bully like he was
in the 12th grade and I was in the
eighth grade and then
um full-grown man was picking up pretty
I mean but he wasn't a bigger dude he
was just picking on me and and this was
in high school I was walking up the
stairs and I was getting to the top of
the stairs and he was walking down and
he spat right in my face as I just
reached the top of the stairs and then
he starts to walk down the stairs like
no Biggs turns his back on me so I kick
him in the back and he goes you know
falls down the stairs okay cool then
later that day I met my locker and here
he comes right because I ran away
here he comes and he grabs me and he's
like hey you know whatever and I'm like
terrified of this guy I'm in the in
Canada where I grew up it was eight to
twelve in her high school I'm in the
eighth grade I'm only
240 pounds at this point anyway he's not
I mean he's a buck 40 or something and
he's like think and I was like leave me
alone and I'm like getting scared and he
I don't remember how we got into it but
I ended up grabbing him and just like
ragdolling him against the the the the
[__] lockers like
just like losing Consciousness and like
blood coming out of his nose and ears
and my guidance counselor Mr Bourgeois
was like running down the hall going
William stop
also kind of laughing
and then you know brought me to his
office he's like you're not in trouble
but don't you know try not to don't use
your strength yeah it was sort of that
weird like you know oh we have this uh
we have this uh with this pet bear and
it's really nice and and then it forgets
that it's playing and just every once in
a while and knock someone's [__] head
off but it's a nice bear so uh yeah and
then you find football and you're like
oh this is this is more fun giving my
friends brain damage right tackle I was
a center and a nose tackle on defense
what were you Senator you were the big
guy yeah yeah but it was the short big
guy you need that to plug the hole oh
dude oh it was so fun I like the club
that club getting in is my is the is the
[__] I like hurting people Reggie White
back
man dude Reggie White had that move oh
did you his book I never read it he had
a move in the in the 90s where he would
like chocolate rip well that and then he
had the he would like
pretend he was going this way and the
whole momentum would shift and then he
would just go and like launch guys I was
always trying to do assaulted people
yeah like watching he's faking punch
guys well no one's watching in there no
it gets dirty in there in in the NFL
there's what 11 refs or something when
you're playing a high school game
there's like two drunk dudes or the refs
you know you could get away with
anything [__] arrest the rest were
random ass men did you ever have the do
you ever do this and football as a kid I
would do this this is dirty but you like
get a long field down play or like they
score on you and it's just like a bomb
and everyone there like everyone
watching both teams everyone on the
field certainly the refs are like
it's like there's a everyone's looking
this way and it's like here's this
[__] that's been you know doing
whatever all game or through some
[__] dirt in my face and you just
take a run at the dude yeah I got
trouble instantly oh really I I you
sometimes you get in the [__] you might
get ejected but when you get away with
it it's essentially it's assault but
it's I I remember I was editing like our
highlights of the uh the high school
year the football year whatever you're
the editor too well I would always
geeked around with all that cameras and
[__] and making videos of my pals and
stuff and I remember putting like a
couple of those in where it's just like
so then like the coach is watching the I
made a highlight reel anyway hey you
what the [__] are you doing
shop block yeah yeah just like you just
see like this play what's like why is
this in the Highlight Reel it's like
it's like the rest so the alignment just
dogging it and there's like a big
50-yard bomb or whatever everyone's over
there and cameras over here and then all
of a sudden you see some kid just
getting his helmet knocked off Good
Times fun times violence the only time I
ever did it and I felt bad he was mid
putting his mouthpiece in
that's why when I hit him the ref came
up I am going to throw you out right and
I was the captain of the line oh no I
was like oh oh oh I'm sorry oh no like
I'm the example I was like damn I I took
him out yeah or he turned into it my
mouthpiece and I hit his whole elbow
into his everything that's bad it's so
funny it's always fun though the [__]
that you can't do in the NFL now of
course like you know I remember I saw
that movie concussion and I was like I
can't believe I even I mean I loved
football but it's like it's like oh yeah
back then you get like a straight up
concussion your coaches are like you
know take walk around a bit drink some
water or The Stingers where you can't
move your back back when you crunch your
neck in right yeah first time that
happened I I tear it as I was looking up
at the sky yeah like I'm never gonna
walk again yeah it goes back like oh I'm
fine yeah 11. and then you and then you
see in the NFL the rules that they've
changed
uh it's like mind-blowing to me that
back then we were like let me see if I
can you know kill a 17 year old boy you
know what I mean because we're they're
the the the size discrepancy when you're
playing High School football it's we're
not it's not Supreme athletes it's like
here's it's like watching LeBron you
know if wherever farad Academy or was
that
yeah it's like it's like here's here's
someone who is you know definitely going
to be selling Insurance in five years
and there's no way that they should be
on a field at all you know what I mean
like maybe some racket sports or
something and then here's a guy who
could like walk on to the Detroit Lions
at like 18 and it's just like the
biggest like how much milk do you
[__] drink and and that kid is gonna
truck this kid it's anyway hooray for
High School San Dimas High School
football rules
the uh first
the first uh season of UFC was basically
High School football dude there was no
weight limits just don't kill him don't
touch his balls or his eyes that was the
rules on UFC one wait a minute remember
that you could touch his balls do you
remember uh that that guy chemo he was
just taking ball shots the Hawaiian
looking guy with the tats I think he
yeah he's the guy who had his ponytail
ripped off in him
I don't remember that I think if I'm not
I'm probably wrong on I'm probably
fusing a few people these guys yeah this
guy chemo with like a giant Cross
tattooed on his back
and someone like pulled his
ponytail off there was another guy who
you know looked like bolo Young from
Bloodsport just getting punched in the
dick Jesus and then after that they're
like maybe that should take shots and he
couldn't fish hook or I ouch oh Bishop I
gouge everything else is legal do you
remember the the Sumo dude who got the
[__] kicked out of him in four seconds
that man could have he needed help
getting his clothes on yeah and he's
gonna go
my aunt used to date the polar bear
remember the giant like seven foot white
dude in the first like four ufcs no
uh the polar bears the polar bear he's a
big gigantic white dude like maybe like
610 I think he was I remember one of
those first ones there was a guy they're
running the clip package
and I was watching it I remember I was
like 18 years old or something it wasn't
playing anywhere we end up
in this um in a you know a gentleman's
club a strip club because they're
showing it in a neighboring town near my
pal Mo and everyone in there was just
there for the the UFC so like in between
the matches you know a young lady would
come it's like hey you know Jasmine is
stage five Jasmine stage five and the
the young lady would come out and think
and then the the thing would start and
everyone would just be like jump to the
TV and I just remember being like this
is we're watching human cockfights in a
strip club
and and um there was this dude and they
do the clip package and he's a Canadian
guy so I mentioned this to say everyone
in the house was for the Canadian guy
we're outside of Vancouver BC and he's
it's like he's a master of 10 Martial
Arts disciplines he runs the so-and-so
Dojo out of Calgary Alberta whatever so
here's this like red boned like with
mustache and you know this like mullet
and [__] like oh this guy's bad you know
the whole place yeah versus kickboxer
Pat Smith
and Pat Smith is like a kickboxer that's
it okay
so all these disciplines blah blah blah
kick back you know clip package they get
out of you ready you ready let's get it
off and the guy with the 10 disciplines
of martial arts forgets them all
immediately and just goes
and just runs at the kickboxer who's
like this jumps out of the way kicks him
in the mouth and then gets on him and
starts giving him the elbows it was like
this is first of all this is [__]
hilarious and second of all it was like
there's no that you started to learn
like oh Gracie Jiu Jitsu can beat
everything
it's like it got boring right away
because it was just like oh well if you
put here's a remember the guy with one
boxing glove it was like Street Fighter
2 there was a guy with one boxing glove
so how do I remember him for him I
because it was the cast of Bloodsport it
was all these different guys this guy
has a patch yeah this guy has a pirate
gimmick and this guy over here is you
know here's uh you know what's his face
uh Ogre from Revenge of the Nerds and
he's got like a American flag bandana oh
I like him he's cool looking and here's
the kickboxer I don't think he's gonna
do very well he's only got one martial
arts discipline Pat's or this dude has
ten nope
and the ref's going do I stop it no let
him die yeah exactly Big John McCarthy
man right there was the one remember uh
it's a black guy huge and he has this
little Italian he wraps him up full
spread eagle and then elbows him in the
face for 40 seconds and doesn't stop if
you you've seen the clip probably he's
stuck legs wrapped arms wrapped in the
guy he's elbowing him he's clearly
asleep at elbow three he's about 12 deep
and then they come up and stop you've
seen it that's that's amazing yeah UFC
one was basically on right regulated
yeah we'll be right back with some more
brain damage after this what's up guys
taking a moment from this hilarious
episode to talk about one of our
sponsors and that's mint mobile go to
mitmobile.com forward slash Yola and
that's going to allow you to start with
one of their plans at little as 15 a
month unlimited talk unlimited text 5G
data delivered on the nation's highest
speed Network mint mobile is changing
the way that you think and the way that
you purchase your phone plan you can be
at home right now with any phone service
any phone and get mint mobile remember
starting as little as 15 a month by
using our code yellow or go to
mintmobile.com forward slash Yola
inflation is at an all-time high and
mint mobile has found a way to pass the
savings directly to the customer right
now you can go to mintmobile.com and
change your plan over from any single
service that you have you can change to
Mint mobile right now you never even
have to leave the room you're in no
surprise fees there's no overages no
minutes rolling over this is 100
unlimited talk and text high speed data
delivered on the fastest 5G Network in
the nation once again go to
mintmobile.com Yola and get your plans
starting as little as 15 a month thank
you for supporting the brands that
support us back to this episode
no I did not see it I with all of those
I'm not a big fight fan so whenever
something big happens I just like try to
like I'll search YouTube right after it
happens before the [__] gets pulled down
because I'm like not paying to watch
this [__] I don't know who's taking a
dive although
I don't know is Jake Paul legit you look
great I think he's a good boxer but I
also think
Nate Diaz right before he went on says
just remember win or lose this
[__] can't really fight
and that's all he said it's kind of
ominous bro come on does that mean you
just took a dive that's sad but also you
got paid I you see that's the thing is
he got paid I don't think a guy like
Nate Diaz would take a take a pay take a
a fall no I don't think I hope that
means Jake Paul really worked well Jake
Paul is like he's good he looks like a
boxer a lot of again I don't know
anything about the fight game but when I
watch people break it down it's like
they're like oh this guy has he has
what's up he's been working his ass off
so it is
it is interesting to see someone now you
know in the age of the internet someone
is like you know my older brother's
blowing up on Vine and I want to do
videos too and then and now like less
than 15 years later he's beating the
living [__]
what kind of alternate reality are we in
right like if you could like get in a
time machine it's like Jake Paul has a
weird like you know [__] chin beard
and he's covered in tats and he's why
and he's fighting in front of you know
20 000 people and you're not wrong it's
it's it's [__] it's like hit the time
machine and he got warped I came out and
yeah yeah no you're completely right
because
it's the YouTuber's little brother that
little kid with the blonde hair yeah
beating everyone's ass yeah the older
kid you're like oh I guess he's a good
looking dude he's in great shape he does
all sorts of physical humor and stuff oh
now he's on YouTube oh he's becoming a
huge vlogger he's a gigantic star and
then his kid brother's like yeah me too
and he's got rap music and hey you guys
yeah you're doing your thing wonderful
and and then out of nowhere he's like I
think I'm going to be a boxer shut up
five years later watch this
multiple UFC Legends well back to vine I
forgot they were Vine guys
I love oh I never even knew that yeah I
loved Vine and speaking of why that's
where we were talking about Marty
because I feel like some of those clips
I still see daily from your Vine and I
really miss Vine Vine was cool it was
fun short con perfect yeah they really
have much effort it should have been
instead of seven seconds it should have
been three seconds like because nowadays
do you find this thing that like you
know you're flipping through Instagram I
literally like I said I'm a 48 year old
man I
I was on a sketch show where some
sketches were six and a half minutes
long and then now I'm on Instagram and
if something doesn't smell like I'm
gonna like it or think it's funny you
scroll past it in the first second
instant it's crazy and then I feel bad
yeah I make content yeah what people do
to much [__] yeah and then I have people
who I just flip through it's like I like
you like I don't need to see it you know
what I mean like I like that I always
like this guy's [__] yeah and even if
it's important [__] they make a bad one
it's like I don't care I like it it's
like what this one I liked it and I
watched the first 10 seconds of it and
that's all right nice flip past the
Analytics
are all are completely screwed we have
we are watching all of our Algos are
screwed we're all watching [__] that we
shouldn't watch that we don't
necessarily like because we're voting
with our thumbs and uh Jake Paul just
beat the [__] out of Nate Diaz that's
where we're at 2023. yeah Demolition Man
I woke up yeah remember in Demolition
Man remember that movie yeah do you
remember when they say president
Schwarzenegger
oh that's right he's like he became the
governor his popularity became so
massive yeah they changed the law and he
became president yeah she almost got she
almost got real for a second remember he
was the governor of our [__] State
guys for two terms
were like no not a mistake let's bring
him back yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know what that was pretty good hey wild
time in life and he but to his credit he
was not he like stopped being the movie
star immediate like he was only the
governor you're like all right he's made
the jump and then as soon as it was over
he starts being hilarious like he's been
[__] hilarious for 10 years now he's
going like well everything like he's
like
gets into it like into a mustache and
they know an outfit and goes into a gym
and is like you know nobody will
recognize yeah yeah
and then he had the fake ponytail right
yeah yeah with a hat going look at this
you have to you're doing it wrong you
have the wrong form you know who are you
my name is Barry I'm the trainer here oh
okay yeah I'm an All-American Trainor
here very okay Barry where are you from
I am I am from Dayton Ohio
okay where'd you get the accent yeah
Dayton Ohio this is it you've never been
to Dayton but he just starts being nuts
as soon as he gets out of politics which
I appreciate there's a you can't really
parody Arnold Schwarzenegger anymore
he's got he's got two [__] like
donkeys or whatever mules like running
around miniature donkeys at his house
feeding him it is a chocolate chip
cookie you know like insane it's like
what's sillier than that he's like oh
you guys want to make fun of me out
there like I'm a big movie star watch
this I'm mountain biking around my
backyard being followed by donkeys
what's sillier than that you know one of
my donkeys made the [__] so disgusting
that I invited that piece of crap mutton
shkreli over for chocolate chip cookies
instead I put the horseshit into the
cookie then he ate it he said hey this
isn't chocolate chips and I said yeah
neither is this
grab the [__] in his mouth [__] you you
want to cut 700 for HIV pill you piece
of [__] [__] you
this is easy I'm a Republican and I'm
telling you this should be regulated
regulated these should be you shouldn't
be allowed to hike up the price of life
[__] eat this [__] you [__] now I
got it on video because this camera is
everywhere in my house
dude
show this Sunday
I know you're listening dirty play this
video of me rubbing the [__] in Martin
shkarelli's mouth and also here's my
friend Jake Paul beat his ass
be this [__] ass
hey I know you your older brother was on
the [__] you
Vine mine that's why we need Vine back
that's why we need for things like this
no he I think it's funny you guys used
to make similar content on Vine with
lemons I used to make this lemon I used
to do this with all fruits it'd just be
like what if and I'd walk up the trees
or random things and I'd open it up and
just be a bunch of weed fly out okay it
was just fun stupid [__] and when I met
Marty and the for what the first episode
I think we talked about one day
here comes on this
on the shoe talked about the vine lemon
thing it's just there's viral things
that people will always remember and I
think there's like 40 of those on the
internet from fine I would take the
lemons one okay the lemons one the
screaming ones the half gargle throw up
ones it's just that funny it's just it's
just I think it's just a whole
generation's humor and I think that's
why the first thing you said was that
and honestly for me
um I've been a fan for Mad TVs I was a
kid I used to what did I say the first
time I ever smoked weed I drank a gallon
10 pickle juice and watched Mad TV hmm
it's 13.
13. so let me ask you something you're
clearly steeped in the weed culture here
you you smoke for the first time at 13.
yeah that's amazing is that young yes of
course it's very young I I think I was
kind of old for my town like like people
are smoking like sixth grade okay yeah I
I I smoked weed for the very first time
at the age of 36.
I'm dead serious and then wait you're
dead serious yeah I I and I um yeah and
I'm from British Columbia where they
have really good weeds yeah no I was
always you know what my thing is being a
Canadian I was like I am I well I've
always you know I used to you know I
could drink my face off in my 20s and
stuff but luckily never had much of a
hankering for it you know like cheese
sandwiches or my uh Vice I guess but um
but uh you know and all the whatever you
can also put meat in a sandwich so
anyway
um uh I just never got into anything
like that and then you moved La I was
here as a young young guy and I was like
I don't want to get mixed up in the in
anything like I was just you know like
let me just keep my you know Pollyanna
Canadian thing going as long as possible
and I always said when friends of mine
or whatever people be like you never
smoked weed and I'm like I will not
smoke weed until I'm an American citizen
because
I've just heard so many horror stories
of people crossing the border uh actors
coming down here for a pilot season or
something they have a roach in their
pocket or something you know they forget
and Customs can be like okay you're not
coming in for five months you're not
coming in for five years you're not
coming in ever again you know and I'm
living here and I'm working here and I'm
doing we're talking you know after Mad
TV and all that stuff so I'm like that's
not gonna happen so then I became a US
citizen uh years ago and then it was
always in the back of my mind
and uh
and so I was like okay I'm gonna I'm
gonna you know maybe I'll maybe I'll try
it so I I tried it at the first time for
the first time at 36. then I didn't
really dig it for like five years but
then these past like five to seven years
I I don't I haven't I don't drink I
haven't drank in like a dozen years or
so again just not really super into it
but I really do uh really do enjoy Weed
And now when I go back to Canada where I
am also still a citizen uh you know I'm
Blown Away by how incredible uh legal it
is oh dude you can walk there's no
dispensary there's no it's not like a
you know there's no security guard it's
just like it's a storefront window it's
a retail storefront a big weed leaf and
they're like come in I remember me and
some of my buddies that I grew up with a
couple summers ago or something uh maybe
a little longer doesn't matter but uh we
go into this one place it's not a
dispensary it's a place a weed store
it's normal just normal and it's all out
there they don't dude so long as you're
they don't need to card you like for
your age they don't care they don't no
no identification nothing they're like
what do you want
so my friends go in there and uh we're
all you know these are guys I grew up
with we're in our 40s and they go in
there and we're I'm just like buying
some weed and two of these dudes did uh
dabs I've never done a dab I have no
answer this day no I'm not doing a dab
and so these guys but we were like going
for lunch or something you know what I
mean and and these guys look with a like
and then they were like they were on
another planet like and
um yeah hey we're here at lunch what do
you want I don't know maybe some chicken
wings how about this rub dog [__]
there's pretty good I guess can you what
does that taste like tastes like
chocolate cake
um but uh
your brain is like the way we conversate
and go what the [__]
I smoked so much weed that dog [__]
tastes like chocolate cake he really
goes to restaurants where it's dudes
sitting with fifty thousand dollar
[__] dab rigs everywhere just really
there's a certain restaurant
you just take dabs arrest is this Woody
Harrelson's restaurant that no no it's
like a restaurant right off Road day I
won't say where but it's right for Deo
it's like a I felt very odd dabbing
there but there's like a little event
and we're just dabbing in the middle of
the day and he had Mrs Doubtfire sitting
right behind basically had Mrs Doubtfire
behind me in the window behind me in a
wheelchair he's sitting there there's
giant dab right here I try to block it
like this because she was behind me I
felt very odd that's wild but I I still
was just it was the world's changing
yeah man it is it's interesting I I the
stigma
that was attached to weed for so long
obviously calling it a drug when it's
um you know go through goes through way
less of a process than something like
alcohol does and um you know it is very
interesting that
you know it's funny there's you know
those videos where
um where they have like an old person
smoking weed for the first time with
like a grandkid or something
one of my uncles in Italy who's like the
oldest of my mom's siblings who was like
I mean pushing 90 at this point one of
his grandsons did that with him so he's
like on YouTube and I'm watching like
you know one of the Patriarchs of of our
family and like the most old-school
Italian guy great wonderful man just the
sweetest most loving man Uncle Jerry
Gennaro and he's like he's like
and he's like and he basically says in
Italian like you know what it's not for
me like when I was a kid it's like you
know you have a [__] what are they
you know limoncello and a beer and uh
he's like but you're a good kid and I I
get it I understand it was very it was
nice to see and it's also it's like it's
mind-blowing to me that it's like so
acceptable although
you know having done it at 13 I just if
I may I wouldn't advise it I I I don't
like to
I don't like for young people to for me
it's like I don't like for young people
to lean on it so much uh in some ways
even like creatively like people would
go I would have young actors and [__]
people in comedy or whatever go hey Mad
TV you guys are probably pretty smoked
out and it's like no we were everyone
was trying to you know order low carb
lunches and we were drinking wheatgrass
and you know people were pretty chill
over there certainly other people have
their private lives or
um sometimes there was someone with a
problem but there was no culture of
of marijuana certainly we would finish a
show on a Friday night a live show and
go out and have some drinks but
it's mind-blowing now and I also uh you
know as a guy you know I'm a I'm an old
man so I I go like well it's it's cool
creatively if you can you know smoke a
bit of weed get some ideas I can't come
up like I can't write anything while I'm
actually stoned but you can get stone
come up with the weirdest thing jot it
down on your phone come back to it later
go what the hell was it it's not spelled
that wrong yeah but but the rest is good
it's a we are in a weird time I've never
I need to think of stuff let me get
creative that's never been yeah for me
as a kid I just smoked I was like I'm so
curious everyone you know I mean I was a
straight A student math student of the
year kid play football captain I was the
straight educated my sister was the
delinquent I was like this what you want
to do all the time let me try it [__] oh
wow you're gonna be almost pissed like
[__] let me [__] try
and then I was like
all right and which we did at my
grandma's we've watched Mad TV we watch
Cops
oh sorry go on no tops nine to nine to
ten ten to eleven's Mad TV you're just
weren't just smoking weeds no me and my
sister this is me right my very I was my
first time but that's why I did my
grandma's my whole life that's the order
and then at 11 if we can catch some of
us and now we would but it was too old
for me I didn't like that [__] unless it
was Adam Sandler I just didn't think it
was funny but Matt TV is a whole
different story so I grew up on that and
that's one thing I wanted to talk about
is my uncle John the one that I did
smoke weed with all the time uh no yeah
okay I just we did a lot of drugs
together that was my uncle right sure
and he passed away recently but oh I'm
sorry to hear that thank you he was just
the
that's that's one of my best friends
right he was he was the the funny
awesome uncle he's just my uncle he's my
aunt's husband that married in oh wow so
when I was like
yeah and then we just started sneaking
smoking weed together and then we grew
into hanging out every day when I was an
adult I was selling packs and weed and
[__] anyway
um that's what I used to do and all that
but
we constantly and I'm I can quote every
single thing is my favorite skit of all
time I'm just going to say it here is uh
Elvis Elvis in the car oh yeah Elvis in
the car the series I remember the day it
came out because I watched it with my
sister but when YouTube came out it's
like you can YouTube everything that
we've ever seen right okay here's the
search bar so my favorite one is
is the Elvis one when you can see
through metal being the Richard M Nixon
one the same the same skit I quoted a
lot oh that's cool man and it's my
favorite one but I wanted to see I have
a couple questions yeah and therefore
you know how you say you come in a 10
Minute Podcast like it's not me this is
a different person in this room go ahead
and we're gonna talk so I have a couple
impersonations that you've done I'm not
sure if you're down but I have a couple
questions I would ask that person
who Elvis I have a couple people okay
that you've done I'm just I'm a Mad TV
fan that's awesome
I have I have the first six on DVD I
couldn't [__] find them today I tried
to find them this morning don't know
where they're at but I have them in a
box on all my DVDs and uh I have a
couple this I want to throw out there
maybe
2023 versions of these characters okay
okay so
um so I'm gonna throw out one
and uh yeah I just want to see how you
respond to it and how that person would
respond to it does that make sense yeah
I'm trying to I'm trying to word this
right dude you were sitting way lower
than you were before I'm just joking
excuse me oh I'm so stoned dude we can
barely see your eyes over the table am I
that [__] up we've had gasket like
that yeah we had one first half fall
asleep before he was [__] face drunk oh
no it was funny that's amazing it was
pretty funny just someone laying on the
floor he put a mic in front of him like
their John Lennon recording Strawberry
Fields or something
yeah he was laying on the John Lennon
laid on the floor and recorded the
vocals for strawberry fields
Talent yeah yeah those guys now those
guys were on some there was some yeah
there was some stuff some of that wacky
tobacco gets better when they start
doing drugs out in my opinion I don't I
love the Beatles they are my sentimental
yet also legit favorite band of all time
and I don't really [__] with the stuff
before 65. Oh 64 little poppy [__] right
I don't I don't really like I appreciate
it as far as that stuff goes like
they're incredible them and the stones
they're early stuff but and then the
stones became like you know that I mean
just this incredible Rhythm Blues Rock
and Roll
Explosion and you know that's amazing
they're later years but the Beatles
later years just these so much better
drug-induced super weirdos and then
you're speaking of me as a kid you know
sitting there eating a cheese sandwich
I'm sure watching uh Yellow Submarine
and you don't realize it well this thing
is an LSD trip the whole thing and
you're just like oh cool blue meanies
anyway sorry you were going to say
something about Elvis hey kids
hey kids current references here uh hey
no no this is dope as usual podcast this
[__] we talk about yeah we got the
Beatles Hey everybody remember that
Jerry Lee Lewis Great Balls of Fire he
was married to his 12 year old cousin
that [__] weird Wolf Man
it's coming up next all right take over
the rest of the episode
is the wolf man we got the turtles after
this break and a superset from Paul
Revere and the Raiders
do you do impersonation yeah it sounded
pretty good that's my Wolfman Jack
people love that people love my wolf man
hey you know what the thing is when
people do and go oh I love that we're
gonna be [__] friends yeah so that
that's fine because there are people we
just talk about and people in the
comments never heard of that group thank
you now I'm listening do you remember
watching Sergeant Pepper's for the first
time so listening to it watching the
movie oh I've never seen the movie I've
never seen Sergeant Pepper oh I've never
seen the movie good the Bee Gees are the
pictures it's that's right that's why I
don't give a [__] oh
no you have to watch it's a great movie
yeah but but is it does it have anything
to do with the Beatles or they read all
the covering the Beatles songs all the
songs and everything are Beatles
soundtrack and then what is it Aerosmith
when they're brand new is like The
Villain band okay I'm gonna check that I
have Steve Martin in there as uh uh Mr
Max bang bang Maxwell the Maxwell silver
hammer he's in there as like a doctor
and Alice Alice Cooper's in it all crazy
or no
Frank Zappa's in it doing the uh wild
ass song so they have different artists
I've never seen it it's a musical all I
know is the iconic image of the Bee Gees
in the those you know those it's a great
movie General uniforms yeah whatever yes
and I'm just like past like I didn't
care although if you love The Beatles
it's one of my favorite I watched when I
was like seven years old and I just I've
loved it ever since I'm gonna check that
out
oh it's it's great dude like he's saying
I was a little kid seeing all this [__]
having no idea this was all acid deep
references and [__] oh wow yeah that
makes sense your dad yeah yeah your dad
was on some different [__] Marty's dad's
a musician from the east coast and uh
Marty's he's also a musician from the
East Coast but maybe your dad would like
to listen to Led Zeppelin a little more
than just just 50 Cent non-stop
but uh oh my God can we get back into
this I'm sorry I have a couple people I
wanted to ask you a couple questions
yeah yeah so Mr Robert De Niro all right
okay Mr Roberts new I saw you had
another kid at 79 years old yeah and how
are you taking that you know
usually you have a kid when you're
younger
but then
we have a Kevin year old
you go to the store with the kid and
stroller it would say and your grandson
you say no
no
it's my race my son
why'd you have a kid song you say
can't stop [__] young ladies
I'm gonna say it
I love acting
I love having sex with
younger women
I don't know I don't oh there's a screen
of things I'm not going to look at that
I don't understand I don't know what I'm
saying
that was pretty much it you have sex
then nine months later
baby comes out you get the name of
whatever you want
I called I called my baby
raging bold the film by Martin Scorsese
his first name is Raging Bill raging
ball the film by Martin
his last name is Scorsese
different when people I can do
impersonations actually look like the
guy so it's always that fish I can't do
an impersonation without like trying to
look like the person yeah well that's
what helps you sound like him I guess
but like there are some impersonations
where I'm like I don't look or sound
like this person and it's [__] wild
that I'm trying to
contort my face to look like do Oprah
Winfrey
okay I'm Oprah Winfrey no that's not
that's your voice all right hold on let
me explain the face is this Oprah
Winfrey yeah pretty good I'm Oprah
Winfrey good Oprah Winfrey will you're
lighting another joint dude how many
okay you're I I know at least I agree
with you yeah I still want to smoke out
smoke you out it's yeah if I'm not gonna
start smoking you're just gonna start
blowing it in my face no it's cool no
it's cool blow it right in my [__] I
got a question
oh no no oh is there another
impersonation oh yeah I got a couple
um here we go I'm ready okay
Jesse Ventura what do you think about
all these alien videos popping up and
these aliens running around well a lot
of people now are saying that these uh
aliens might be from a different
direction they got uh David grush who
was a high security clearance
intelligence guy and uh he's saying
trying to explain the third and fourth
dimension to me you couldn't even
explain the third or fourth grade
college boy you're trying to tell me
that or they're coming from deep in the
ocean I tell you about the ocean I live
in the Baja I haven't had a bath in
about three years I just go into the
salt water and let it cleanse me and I
always have lots of scrapes and cuts
because I've gotten into falconing and I
don't like to use the gloves when I
Falcon and because I'm always naked
on the bar laying on the log getting
some sun on my skullet uh sometimes the
Falcon will come up and mistake my [__]
and balls for a small rodent
I might get I might get typhoid from the
uh from their claws because of all the
rodents that they're picking up in the
Baja and the brown brush but if I go in
the ocean for a half an hour then it's
fine hey David grush how about you when
I go snorkeling to 5 000 feet below how
long can you hold your breath underwater
David grush I bet it's not more than 10
seconds [__] but if you went I'd go
snorkeling with just just a snorkel to
the bottom of the Marianas Trench and
I've never seen any of these uh
purported UFOs uh that uh apparently
predate to humankind history uh
underneath the Bermuda Triangle and I've
I've flown from also I've I've jumped
out of so many Indonesian planes
flying at 38 000 feet pulling my Chute
about 20 feet from the surface of the
ocean Landing with a big smack as the
parachute rips into several pieces so
snorkel my way down to the Mariana's
Trench where fish have lights sticking
out of their heads and I haven't seen
any [__] UFOs flying out of there
I'll tell you where they're where
they're coming from there's one Chop
Shop in Merced California
and these guys are stealing car parts
and they're making UFOs or uaps as they
call them now unidentified aerial
phenomena I don't care what the [__] you
call it those things a lot of them have
super trap Mufflers on them and they
make a loud noise but the ones I've been
in have some pretty good sound systems
I'm starting to morph into other
characters I thought it was some pretty
good sound systems I like to have sex in
a car have sex in a boat I've even had
sex in the UFO with an alien
aliens some of them live thousands of
years I'm you know aliens are always
cradle robbing me because I'm So Young
because I'm in my 70s
and they say can you impregnite us we
want to make it we want to make the best
actor on our planet please have sex with
the women I say how old are they this
one's two thousand years old no too old
and then they show me you know it looks
like the blue lady and uh Guardians of
the Galaxy I said I'll do it she looks
like uh Zoe Saldana okay
I'll have sex with you alien
let's make a little baby call them alien
Raging Bull the movie by Martin Scorsese
De Niro
Robert De Niro and I like to hang out
Robert De Niro Robert De Niro comes down
to the Baja to Mikasa and uh we just
have some scrambled eggs on tortilla
just you know put some Tapatio on that
and have a good old time smoking weed
and having Falcons rip and tear it or
dick and balls as we pass out from Two
Joints laying on a log
have a good time sorry
what the I don't know I'm stoned because
of you guys now I'm on some stoned rant
that was what I imagined Tom Brady's
rant was like yeah
[Laughter]
hey guys Tom Brady here does everyone
want to hear my Jesse Ventura
impersonation here it goes I don't know
what David grush is thinking but I've
been to the bottom of the Marianas
Trench how long can you hold your breath
underwater [__] folks these are jokes
good Jesse Ventura Tom Brady I'm gonna
be on I'm so impressed that you can
remember all of these things I don't
remember anything you you looked back
Oh you mean Oh you mean like the things
that I said earlier I'm just not as
stoned as you I can't even see your eyes
you're under the table Thomas I just see
the top of your hair
you are embarrassing yourself sir I know
you've been at it since you're 13 but
please you [__] beginner it's like a
noob over here yeah you Rook
hey you want to start boxing oh god
let's no
what
why don't you just why don't you just
ditch all this incredible uh setup in
the studio and everything and start
damage your body I'm gonna start growing
a beard now yeah
just that's the other thing is he's
trolling us with his with his beard so
you can't see his chin there you go I
hate his beard I have respect for him as
an athlete and Logan Paul who's having
some of the most incredible matches in
the WWE I'm sure we'll get to it dude
he's amazing
like Edge they feel like Edge he is
built like Edge he's
um
you like wrestling of course you like
wrestling everybody loves wrestling
um he he was built for it he's athletic
as [__] he's physical comedian uh and
can do it and has been training hard at
you know the whole the thing and
everyone and training one-on-one with
Sean Michaels who's one of the greatest
in-ring performers of all time
incredible and then he has the he he can
talk for days he's incredible on the mic
and he's a natural heel and he leans
into it I'm actually it's like I hate
the whole and this is funny because I've
done [__] with them like wrestling stuff
and uh been fortunate enough to appear
in things and when we do like you know
cross promotion or for Mad TV or this or
that and we did one with the Three
Stooges too the movie and it's like um I
always hate it as a wrestling purist as
I like to say about myself I don't like
it when celebrities get into wrestling
because you're watching like Jay Leno
put Hulk Hogan in a headlock and [__] in
the WCW in the 90s it's like no I don't
remember that at all dude they did this
garbage with like and it's like what
Hulk Hogan you know it was one of the I
mean the guy's only he's Hulk Hogan he's
Superman and it's like sure in the 90s I
mean you got an inch shorter so what is
he now six six three bills and Jay Leno
that's my Robert De Niro everybody
um and yeah but Logan Paul doing that
stuff I was like Ugh don't do this
nobody wants to see this and then as
soon as he had his first match I was
like interesting wonder if it's a
one-off nope there's another one now I
was at WrestleMania this year oh wow and
he was went one-on-one with Seth Rollins
who's
again he's in the mold of Shawn Michaels
Seth roll nobody there there's wrestlers
as good as Seth Rollins but he's at the
top of the list with like a Brian
Danielson and guys like that like Seth
Rollins is Seth Rollins and and uh
and
Logan Paul's have had an awesome match
with him it was
mind-blowing I've never seen it live oh
really no it's an experience man it's
speaking of weed I smoked you know
WrestleMania was a two-day event it was
at Sofi this year so I had to go you
know
yeah dude it was at Sofi and it was it
was insane it was Insanity it was it was
a really great show you know I mean I've
seen every WrestleMania blah blah I'm a
big wrestling fan and um so my wife and
I went and and so we
if we get there and I'm like okay and I
start smoking as we're like walking just
like you're gonna get I'm like it's the
only way I can watch wrestling now it's
the most enjoyable as a matter of fact
my wife who doesn't you know she's not
like a big um not super into pot but if
I can get her smoke a little bit of weed
then she enjoys the living [__] because
it starts to become real to the lay
person who hasn't really watched it
their whole life so she's like hey he
cheated and [__] like that and you're
like yeah now I got you and then the
next day she's like no I don't want to
watch any more wrestling I I watched
wrestling yesterday we did that I'm good
for three months but yeah I went to
WrestleMania
you're like high as [__] like oh my God
I even brought a joint in like maybe no
one will give a [__] whatever anyway uh
and then uh I didn't smoke it and um
smoke a little bit of it and so um yeah
and he had this match with Seth Rollins
I'm sorry I'm getting a contact high and
I'm talking about wrestling it's fine we
let uh read an Iron Sheik tweets a lot
this is our thing rest in peace iron
Chic did you follow his Twitter oh [__]
yeah yeah [__] he goes after Hulk Hogan
so so much yeah that was one of our
ongoing things we just read iron cheek
tweets every couple every couple weeks
for for like eight what eight months
straight yeah he's too funny man [__]
you oh go again you dumb son of a [__]
I have a 10 inch [__] what calm down
cheeky baby calm down what about Hulk
doing the obituary now it's [__]
weird right he did an obituary he put
out a statement right yeah well let me
tell you something dude
cheeky baby dude he handed me that strap
in 1983 brother because they had to get
it from Bob Backlund to me dude they
were starting that Vince had a vision of
Hulkamania dude so I said to cosgro well
hold on dude hold on hold on Marty
cosbro is Sheik's real name dude and I
said hey Shiki baby you're gonna do the
job for me and he said he said Hulk I
don't know this is Hulk Hogan doing iron
cheek no anyway
when
hey guys here's some stuff about
wrestling no one asked to hear about did
you know that when um when Hulk Hogan uh
in 1983 he won the WWF World title from
the iron Sheikh and uh Hulkamania was
born and that
there was um
um oh I'm going up on the name uh-oh uh
Vern ganya who owned the AWA
um that promotion
Vern Ghana gave Chic whatever some
amount of money and or offered him an
amount of money to break Hogan's leg
during that match
because Hulk Hogan had left the AWA
um and if I'm remembering it correctly
he left the AWA to do
um I think he left the AWA to do uh to
do Rocky III to do the movie and play
thunder lips if I'm wrong he left the
WWE and then because he was in the WWE
also for a period in the late 70s or
something early 80s but uh he I believe
he was in the AWA he wanted to do this
movie you know they wanted him to do
Rocky and to play thunderlips and uh he
was and Verne gagne was like no you're a
wrestler you're under contract you're my
guy whatever so he quit and he left and
Rocky 3 blew up and I don't know if it
was before that or coinciding with it uh
Vince McMahon probably had the foresight
to go this is going to be huge and uh
they brought Hogan into the WWE and uh
yeah he left because uh yeah so Verne
gagne kind of put a bounty out on Hulk
Hogan to break his leg Yeah I'm gonna
[__] with my chair now yeah I was
sinking we need new chairs no these
chairs are good
chairs
all right now you were involved speaking
of fighting in one of the most legendary
fight scenes beat down scenes of all
time as far as I'm concerned in a movie
but I'm hoping you might have some sort
of stories about at the hands of Chris
[__] Farley
oh yeah yeah dude yeah I was fortunate
enough to be in uh the movie Beverly
Hills Ninja
starring Chris Farley and uh Chris Rock
and Nicolette Sheridan and uh yeah I was
that was I think about that now
that movie uh shot in 96 here in LA and
I'm like I can't it seems like another
lifetime that I got to do that with
with someone who is one of my absolute
at the top of my list as far as you know
influences and idols and comedy and um
acting like he was the nicest man in the
world awesome he was the sweetest guy
he was such a sweetheart I always tell
this story that um we're sitting there
on um we shot this stuff I'm in the
movie I played this guy uh Chet Walters
who's uh you know he's uh he makes
counterfeit money you know he's like at
the Beverly Hills Bank note hey how are
you Chad Walters come on in what can I
do you for and uh because eventually uh
that character gets subdued or by Farley
and Nicola Sheridan and then he takes
that guy's place when the bad guys pick
him up in the van and he's like and he's
like hey how are you and it's like oh
it's that guy it's the same that's the
same fat guy right so he it was like
reverse engineering where and I I was
fortunate enough to do
a movie the year before with the same
director Dennis Dugan who's done a bunch
of incredible iconic comedies and he
directed Happy Gilmore the year before
and so the next year and I was in that
and then the next year he said uh you
should put yourself on tape I think you
could do this role because it was
literally
you know a fat guy with a mustache he's
in a couple scenes
and then Chris Farley it's like the
character is gonna be like this you know
he's from Chicago you know like it
reminds me of the Bears character it's
exactly that he's just this Wisconsin
you know middle uh you know just Midwest
guy so at any rate I'm in the movie
we're sitting there on set
and we're outside and these these dudes
walk by they're probably like 20 years
old or something and they they walk
there's this fencing and [__] and they
walk by and they clock they see Chris
Farley there
sitting um you know in this chair
outside they run away
20 minutes later they come back with
like dog-eared posters of Tommy Boy and
black sheep and like you know worn out
VHS tapes and they were like you know in
a Sharpie and they you know wanted to
meet Chris and get an autograph
there's a security guard over there and
Farley was like let him in Letterman
come on let him in so they come in and
he spent a bunch of time with them and
I'll just never forget just watching him
write like a novel on these kids poster
Tommy Boy poster just like and he is you
know I think the thing I didn't of
course know Chris Farley well in any way
I got to hang out with him a very little
bit and then I got to do this movie
thing and
you know just you know like saw him we
get a couple things I got to hang out
and uh but he he um
he was if I may I feel like
I think it's I think everyone that
watched him knows that that's just a
genuine article that's who he was
as a matter of fact my buddy Tommy
blacher whom I mentioned was in the
Chicago comedy scene in the 80s and 90s
and stuff and he goes he goes oh even if
Farley never became you know if he never
went on Saturday Night Live or any did
anything of that you would have people
to this day going oh funniest guy I've
ever seen it ain't
so and so and so and so from the movies
it's this [__] dude who has a string
of stories and oh you got to see his
impression of his 600 pound dad trying
to get out of a lazy boy like that's the
funniest thing in the world you know
what I mean and apparently he used to do
that but he was so true blue and he as
he's signing this thing he just kept
saying to the guys ah thanks guys ah
thanks thank you God thanks he said
Thanks a hundred times
and was just sweet to everyone in the
crew he was one of those people that
you're like
the crew was like they're working but
they're also kind of not working because
it was just a joy he was a joy to be
around
and all those guys like like I said I
did Happy Gilmore in the and uh Adam
Sandler you know one day we're just
whatever we're leaving uh the set and
there's just a couple Vans and people
are going to lunch
to wherever the you know the trailers
and stuff and and um and uh Sandler's
getting in the van and there's these
couple neighborhood kids on their bikes
that are like you know like pull up on
this movie set and here's Adam Sandler
and he's going into the van and he sees
them and he just goes don't steal
anything right and they laugh and and
then everyone goes to lunch he comes
back the kids are still there he spent
like you know 15 20 25 minutes I don't
know how long just hanging out with the
kids we're back on the clock you know
the the ad or whoever these you know
like the guys with the headsets are like
where's where's Adam he's outside
talking to those kids and he's not
coming in until he's done talking to the
kids and not because he's you know
trying to be a mensch or something not
because it's gonna get picked up by
there's no internet yeah he's [__]
hanging with those kids because they
watch him on Saturday Night Live and
these guys you know watched Farley on
Saturday Night Live in these movies and
it meant the world to them and he was
just the sweetest man man and I think
you know it's obviously I mean it's a
terrible terrible loss because he's just
he was just an angel of Comedy for real
just one of the
funniest there's nothing funnier there's
nothing funnier than the funniest Chris
Farley I mean this it's like Seth
Rollins you can be as good no there's
yeah it's like there are things that are
as funny as that comedy is completely
you know uh uh subjective am I saying
that is it subjective or objective
subjective see I'm Jack contact high I
forgot what subjective meant
um but there's nothing funnier
than Chris Farley doing like even I
remember there was that one sketch where
it was this uh British toothpaste
remember this one where they they're
they're like it's the British toothpaste
it's good for and all of their teeth are
nasty are nasty because it's like the
the the the Trope of British people not
having good teeth about the coffee one
never mind oh there's that one too three
[__] lines and it's the funniest
thing in the world he freaks out on
everybody but he's he's in the uh he's
in the it's like the toothpaste it's
mcewen's toothpaste or whatever thing
and they're going and everyone's doing
the bit and they're going around this
Pub and it's this two commercial like
pre-tape thing and then it's just far
away with these giant Lamb Chop
sideburns going and it tastes great on a
cracker and eats it and you're like
one [__] line like they're he's he's
just kind of the the funniest person to
ever to ever be the funniest person not
you know there's the funniest uh comedic
actor there's the funniest stand-up
comedian which is the funniest you know
radio like Howard Stern is the best at
what you know he does what you know like
here's the funniest podcaster or
whatever Chris Farley is just the
funniest overall person anyway this
might be a stupid question did he ever
do stand up I don't believe so I don't
think so you guys are kind of similar
like when you were just describing him
you're kind of describing yourself too
like your similar careers
hold on Marty I don't know about that
dude that's what we call sacrilege
brother that's a [__] straight up lie
no he yeah look he he went uh through
you know the Second City and all that
stuff and I I don't believe that he if
if he did I never saw any of it maybe he
did maybe he jumped up on stage like a
comedian though well I think people just
say comedian about anyone who's funny
yeah you know what I mean like that's
and there's yeah that's true there's
there's nothing but uh comedic
performers and improvisers that have
gone through Saturday Night Live
obviously that never never did stand up
yeah I mean Will Ferrell [__] one of
the funniest [__] you know it's
like Molly Shannon stand up
um yeah same thing at Mad TV I mean
there's people that do both
and that's amazing if you can do both
yeah uh and you are I shouldn't say
that's amazing that you can do both but
it's amazing that people can have a
career at both uh if you're good at one
thing because they don't they don't
necessarily translate they're very
different animals I know you've had all
the biggest podcasters in the world
trying to like peer pressure you and
getting into like stand up right I don't
know about that either Marty I've heard
them all like everybody's trying to get
you to do stand up oh well Bobby Lee uh
who's one of the biggest podcasters in
the world was on Mad TV of course and he
we I did his podcast a few years ago
um uh
and more recently but a few years ago
when I was on tigerbelly he was like you
know because that's what Bobby and I
talk about but he gets he quickly gets
pissed off
he's like [__] you you know what don't
ever do it [__] you just screw you I
don't want to talk about it I don't want
to talk about it because he'll bring it
up like why the [__] what's wrong with
you why don't you do and I'm like well
and I have my reasons or like you just
want to hear it what he doesn't want to
hear it yeah then he's just like well
you're wrong shut up I don't want to
talk about it I gotta go actually bye
um but but uh yeah I don't know I I
think that they're I think that I mean I
love great stand-up I you know some you
know like we had when I was a kid we had
the we had the albums we had you know
prior and and Carlin and Steve Martin
and all that [__] in the house
um and I I think stand-up is absolutely
I mean there's nothing better than great
stand-up just someone getting up on
stage and
telling a story or or just going through
their set for an hour and a bit is uh
it's an incredible talent but yeah it's
it's
different I I think that I think that
it's uh you know I don't know it's a
different it's a completely different
thing and I think it's a different thing
for an audience uh you know like seeing
Bobby's a great example because he does
both seeing Bobby on Mad TV you're
laughing for a a bunch of reasons at
what you know why his performance is
funny and what he's doing is hilarious
and when you go see him do stand up
you're laughing for a couple similar
reasons but the rest of them are totally
different and it's a testament to like
you know I mean Bobby's one of the
funniest people I've ever met certainly
so it's like
it's a testament to being able to be an
artist in two different things I mean
Bobby's
you know he acts and does [__] like that
he's on that show now
um the second season of and just like
that the Sex and the City reboot which
my wife is watching right he's the um
we just watched the first movie right he
does a podcast or something in the show
right I've only caught what's the first
what's the first one ah okay see I
watched a little bit of it because like
I said my wife is watching it so but uh
otherwise I would not uh didn't watch
the original series and wouldn't know
that Bobby's in it so if I ever talk to
Bobby about acting and he's like I don't
know it's like you're on a big [__]
say a bunch of [__] yeah he's an actor
sitting everywhere I feel like he
doesn't even want to admit that he's
definitely not admit but I don't think
he even thinks of himself as an actor
that's my thing he's just a funny
[__] guy we I did a movie actually a
year ago or so
um
and and the director was like we're
going to try and get Bobby Lee to do
this other part and I was like I was
like uh really and he's like yeah you
know if you want to mention it to him
and I was like yeah I'm mentioned to him
but but I forgot to and then he I was
showing up to do tigerbelly and this is
whatever like over a year ago and you
know I'm walking up and he goes and he
goes hey man I'm doing that movie that
you're that and I was like what do you
mean what movie he's like yeah we're
doing a movie together and I'm like oh
my God you're doing it
it's like he just people want him in
everything it was awesome to get to
anytime I get to share the screen with
with Bobby Lee it's fun because I feel
like we fall back into the you know the
old Mad TV stuff it starts what movie
was it it's uh it hasn't come out yet
it's called the throwback it's with uh
Justina Machado
and Greg Sulkin and Michelle Randolph
and myself and Bobby's in it
um but yeah and Justina is incredible
she's the the lead in this movie
um and it's about you know Justina
Machado she was the the lead in the um
in the uh oh now I'm forgetting the name
of the show is the Netflix reboot of
Norman lear's
uh
never mind the weed don't worry yeah
here look how much I've smoked
um
um uh uh one day at a time that was the
name of the show one day at a time and
uh she was uh she was the lead to that
she's just a tremendous actor
can I tell you one of the funniest
things that I've ever seen like how you
talk about Chris Farley video clip I
share all the time
so uh back in the day I started out
working for a fighter and the kid this
past weekend back episode one wow Rogan
Adam Kroll all those guys that's like a
graphic designer apparel designer oh
cool so I was there for the whole ride
wow uh we did the fighter and the kid 3D
oh yeah 12 part
sketch series that they did one of the
funniest things of all time was this
episode called bully
yeah
terrorizing Brennan and Brian yeah
they're showing up to the studio he's
kind of just took over the whole podcast
and then they try to kill him and they
can't kill him right he's just this
impossibly annoying
uh version of myself I am extremely
annoying and uh yeah I'm like hanging
out in the studio and like they can't
get rid of me and I'm in the office and
like you know raiding the fridge and
opening up Tupperware and stuff and
eating whatever and they're like hey
will maybe you should and I get
really just really obtuse and in their
face about everything and then I just
remember the end of it was they they
beat the [__] out of me and stabbed and
punched me like in the trunk of a car
like I was in Goodfellas or something
Billy bats like just bleeding in the I
have a selfie somewhere on my phone of
me going with like just my face covered
in blood clearly in the trunk of a car
taking a selfie and and then they I
think they drag me up like on a like in
a construction site or something on a
pile of dirt and I'm still not dead
still talking still talking [__] they
open up the trunk stab them with the
shovel yeah right you guys yeah you call
that murderer
that was fun but Brian is unconscious
like he's another one of those guys that
like I if I goof around with Brian it's
like we're like you know we're like two
twins who like yeah juggling bowling
pins while smoking a cigarette and you
know it's like you know he's just the
same kind of uh
idiotic sense of humor if I may yeah
it's funny because I
I've been living on here for like 10
years I'm from Buffalo but when I was in
Buffalo I connected with Brian when he
was doing the Brian Cowan show oh really
yeah cool and then when I moved out here
I reached out to him and he put me on
got me into the whole podcast wow that's
Brian and then inadvertently right when
I was meeting Thomas and like deciding
okay I'm gonna do my own thing now he
like linked me with the biggest person
in the video world that got me on like
real commercials real TV shows like
Brian was the ultimate plug for that I
could never think of enough that's cool
I see I think that Brian Brian's a
sweetheart and he's one of these guys
who I don't think he knows
like the level at which some of the
people that he knows yeah he doesn't it
was like that he's just like oh I got a
friend that does that yeah like he'll he
put me on the phone with people it could
be some random guy that he knows or it
could be a top Hollywood show runner
right he wants to start a podcast here
yeah talk to him yeah yeah I remember
yeah yeah Brian's amazing for that he's
one of those people who's like what are
you a [__] idiot why aren't you doing
stand up that's what I was really
referring to yeah yeah and then and then
but then from there it devolves when we
start joking around talking about
chimpanzees or something you know like
it's never it we I don't think that
we've had a serious conversation in the
in the years that I've known him that's
that's not possible and one other thing
I mentioned yeah
you guys really make him look and sound
so small when he came on our show he is
not that small of a guy six foot
he was a little little man right no no
no not at all no because he's always
hanging around with big guys yeah he's
fascinated with he has boy crushes on
everybody he's always talking about I
mean it's just it's like it's fine it's
totally it's like whatever uh that's
that's and and and he's you know he's I
don't know he's he's just obsessed with
like men so he's like look at that guy
he's so big and strong and you're like
all right oh my best wow I wonder what
his stomach muscles look like you're
like yeah I guess good guy but then I'm
a guy who like I watch wrestling and um
you know like you know it's it's it's
like I guess I don't like I think the
same thing like oh that guy has a great
physique Logan Paul are you kidding me
great physique guys original name good
as Vince McMahon would take strong name
oh strong name good luck good physique I
tell you what pal
um
uh and so I'm that same way but Brian
will do that with like people just
walking down the street you can't make
it awkward one time one time
one time I was uh having lunch uh with
some friends and one of my friends is
you know big tall handsome actor guy
right and just in the way that uh
everyone can agree on uh it's a very
handsome man and Brian came and met us
and he and he meets my friend and that
guy's a ham too this friend of mine and
uh so Brian's like oh wow you're you're
striking gee whiz and Brian starts being
very Brian talking about oh look at the
Symmetry and geez you have bowling balls
for shoulders or whatever Brian says and
the guy goes my buddy is like Falls in
line with the humor he's a funny guy and
he he's wearing sunglasses he goes yeah
yeah that's right check this out takes
his glasses sunglasses
you know whatever is beautiful blue eyes
and Brian goes
wow wow and then I think they were that
probably graduated to the two of them
showing each other their own um pictures
of their penises on their phone I would
imagine like I would imagine yeah yeah
let's take some pictures together so I
think Brian's just fascinated with the
um with the male form but that's you
know a lot of uh so is Michelangelo you
know what I mean what I'm trying to say
is Brian's an artist though fig Leaf in
front of your junk or not an artist
great explanation yeah that started for
me I thought he was little he's an
artist he's an artist he's a six foot
he's a five ten and a half five
eleven-ish artist yeah but he's always
he hangs out with all of these guys
these big you know the UFC guys and all
that stuff so it's like of course he
looks small compared to these that's
what he surrounds himself he just looks
like a you know he always looks like a
football coach everywhere there you go
that's what it is that's what he looks
he needs a clipboard or some [__] yeah
he looks how to say it earlier but what
does he look like he looks like
this is another current reference but I
don't know he just looks like a Marty
Schottenheimer or something coaching the
Chiefs in the 90s like just this guy
looks like your substitute teacher or
something and he's constantly around
giant men that's where he's most
comfortable that's where he gets his
that's his Muse that's his inspiration
for the art that comes you know that's
what that's why all of his stand-up is
about these things yeah he should do a
stand-up special just called
um just
male muscles that would be a good one he
just talks about
the biceps the
triceps people like what who gives a
[__] shut up dude that's his next
special shut up dude no I saw a headline
I wanted to get you quick and put on
Dana White announcing it's going to be a
billion dollar Club the Rome Coliseum
it's probably all [__] between Elon
and Zuckerberg they're saying it's
happening at the Roman Coliseum that's
where Dana White's out on Instagram I
mean look if you're gonna do it yeah why
not and I don't know what the rules are
in Italy about the Coliseum and what
they allow in there I don't want that
type of [__] I would imagine so and Dana
White's trying to drum up some publicity
to perhaps make it happen God knows
makes sense yeah but who do you got who
do I got it with either uh Well
everybody's taking Zuckerberg because
he's because he's he's look again I
don't follow the the fight game or
anything me neither but he's he's do
he's rolling around on a floor doing jiu
jitsu and he's got some kind of belt you
know he's got the pistachio belt or
something you know some shitty fourth
level belt right but it's like that's
more than uh what's this uh uh Alan muck
as I like to call him uh is doing that
guy's doing you know he's on you know
he's on uh we've all seen them whatever
I'm I look I catch myself in the mirror
and I'm like what the [__] happened to
you but you know this guy's out there
with his shirt off uh you know in Monaco
on a yacht and just looking like cottage
cheese yeah it's he's gonna get his head
kicked in he could get you know
everyone's you know kid sister beat his
I don't know I don't think that's how
you feel I thought it was probably
different because when I asked him he
thought the old man strength on Elon has
just been a completely that's a good
point and his head is big he's got a
huge Dome that could probably and did
you know Mark Zuckerberg is five foot
seven no I didn't know that okay see now
we're getting into some UFC one [__]
because we're gonna be it's going to be
it's dude that's like UFC one no way
classes punch him in the dick just don't
fish hook them it's gonna be Elon Musk
with his big huge wide face that could
just take tons of punches right and and
he sucks you you know he doesn't know
how to fight he's going to be like that
like that guy with the 10 disciplines
you know in UFC one
yeah I have but yeah this is that's why
you imagine it
just imagine this massive man he I don't
know how big or small he is but if he's
much bigger than than Mark Zuckerberg
then that is a Difference Maker he's the
sumo wrestler in that in that example
UFC one where it's like here's the Sumo
wrestle guy and here's the other guy
who's just gonna kick him in the face
you know a couple dozen times until you
have to stop it I still got I still got
Mark Zuckerberg but that's maybe because
I uh
that's maybe because I'm just like
bummed on what Elon did to Twitter but
having said that I don't give a [__]
about Twitter because mine got hacked by
a Russian crypto bot last fall and I
tried to get it back like twice you
weren't kidding at all no oh yeah I
don't give a [__] about Twitter yeah I
got really hacked it yeah and then I
tried to get it back and I couldn't I
was like I don't [__] care I don't
really tweet anyway they have your name
and your account still yeah okay but
they're posting like crypto [__] I have
no idea yeah they're posting a bunch of
spammy [__] really it's like spammy
spammy spammy [__] and then it's like
you want a couch
they still post things of me or it's
just that no that wasn't the last post
oh okay before it got taken yeah but the
look the internet is so deep now that it
doesn't even matter to me it doesn't
even like have my Twitter I don't care
like to me it just doesn't it it doesn't
it does not matter what like [__] like
that if you're not used using it if
you're using it it matters but if you're
not it's like I don't really give a [__]
it's actually a testament to how we
shouldn't pay as much attention to
social media as we do that you lose an
app or forget something or delete your
whatever and then you're like oh this is
totally fine
throw your phone in the ocean you gotta
say damn even just a little bit because
I've been taken down so many times like
one day I'm gonna find you the Twitter
just didn't give a [__] when you try to
tell them about your copying hacked I
mean what do you do you email the thing
you fill out the form and they either
give it back to you or they don't so
they were like so I guess I don't know I
don't know who the hell the email goes
to you just whatever you click on the
thing and you write a dumb email to
whoever the hell reads those please help
me out yeah it's like I don't know what
the you know and it's like it's not like
I know
uh I guess Jack Dorsey at the time
I have no inroad is what I'm saying like
I don't I don't have an in at uh Twitter
so I think because of what he did it's
no you know you know what I'm happy
about what uh Elon Musk is doing to
Twitter because Twitter hack Twitter let
my my Twitter get hacked but now it's X
so you know what
I'm going with Elon yeah what a
turnaround I love the range of emotions
I realized I'm actually happy that that
Elon Musk you know what I think is
happening we actually we talked about
this on duty but I think that you know
look he he has wanted to make X happen
forever he had a web he bought the
domain in 1999. he tried to make PayPal
X he called it X Peter Thiel renamed it
PayPal and he's you know one of his
children has a few x's in their name
right like he's he's into the letter X
that's that's you know that's fine
uh weird especially when it's like
everything like extreme was 25 years ago
like we don't really use true yeah like
Backstreet Boys ends with a z we don't
do that anymore so but this [__]
you know this weird I don't know where
this Nordic weirdo is like I like X oh
no he's from South Africa whatever this
weirdo is like X okay
I think he's doing it because he because
he likes he wants to make X the all
together I think that's all true I'll
tell you where the troll is but I think
he wants to make this the One-Stop
shopping for all of your social media
even banking he wants to do I don't know
how you don't do that and don't use x
banking
um and make it everything make it a
network for media do shows do just not
Twitter just not Twitter but how do you
how do you if you've got something
that's the bane of your existence that's
like Twitter which
you know legally he was forced to buy it
because of I don't know the particulars
Google it but he he made the offer on
Twitter and he was held to it and I
think he didn't want to spend the money
on it but he was forced to buy it
he's got 350 billion dollars he doesn't
care he's doing what he wants with it he
fires most of the staff has to bring
them back because he's like oops we
don't know how to work that part
um now it's real scaled down he's [__]
it up and I feel like
you've got I want to make X over on this
side I want to do this thing this whole
app and Twitter's the bane of my
existence because it is would be the it
would be a huge competitor to X and uh
it's also something that I've been
forced to buy I know I'll Rebrand it as
X and I don't give a [__] if it loses
however much whatever insane percentage
of its value that it's lost it doesn't
matter he's got more money than anyone
any human being
could
ever use in any way to the degree that
he [__] bought Twitter for 44
billion dollars it's absolutely insane
anyway I feel like I feel like it is the
it's the biggest troll of all time
I am getting rid of the thing that you
love because I'm Elon Musk the troll and
he is a Troll he's trolley as [__] his
Twitter account I thought that was a
fake account sure absolutely the [__] he
says he's responding to everybody and
it's nuts it's stupid it's like a jake
Paul's a box knocking people out yeah
same thing goes back to the rich man the
world's trolling yes that's right the
richest man in the world is is would
rather be an Internet troll hey you can
read with Rogan trolling people oh [__]
for real trying to pretend that he that
he's not stoned that was amazing he's
like no no I have a superhuman brain
that doesn't it's fine just react to
this yeah I also get uh drunk off of
sour milk like the aliens in uh Alien
Nation
um there's another deep cut hey yeah hey
kids remember the Texaco Comedy Hour
with Pat Boone
never mind 1959 1959. hey hey everybody
we got Sid Caesar with your show of
shows
some of the most current sits users of
[__] genius though all right I'm
gonna have a puff oh
there we go one Puff
one delighted there you go
damn guys we really enjoy legendary now
yeah we really went through a string
of of just brain spurts here guys I'm
trying to remember what we were talking
about and I don't remember which is
great we're talking about the Roman
Coliseum and uh damn see 36 that's what
happened until 36. I'm just the least
stoned that's all don't be like wow he
pulled it back it's a thing we were
talking about seven minutes ago and I'm
not as [__] up as you guys that's all
right right maybe but I think this
happens to me on the daily
I I I have
look I think it's if I can say something
self-deprecating so I talk too much
anyway uh I annoy the my close friends
and everybody I know with uh how
sometimes I I tend to ramble okay but
when I smoke some weed friends of mine
are like yo like your stories have
details in them that are completely
unnecessary like we don't need to know
what color the car was you know what I
mean like or my good friends Chad from
the Pod show and uh Marshall cook I like
to call them Marshall joint compound
cook we'll be hanging out with throwing
some weed and then it'll be like I'll be
telling a story and here's the the the
objective over here it's it's the letter
G and all I have to do is a to G and I
just go b c d e f and because I am
filling in stuff to the degree that
they're like who's that guy
I thought this was a story about this
guy yeah but that guy knows him and he
dude you can't you know what you don't
get to tell the story now you told us a
story and you chose to tell us a story
about the guy who the story isn't about
[__] you I'm not listening to the rest
of your story it's called rant City yeah
that's what we do every week yeah good
yeah we just do things like [__] was I
talking about that was a segment what
the [__] was I talking and if any of us
say that we bring up a fan question
[Music]
and then we'll come back that's like the
uh remember that movie Idiocracy I was
gonna say the world is idiocracy of
course and they're the number one show
in the world is my balls that's gonna be
like that's gonna be the biggest podcast
you'd need to start that because that's
gonna be the biggest podcast in about
five to ten years on the planet it's
called what the [__] was this thing this
world like you two short kids yeah just
getting all [__] yeah dumb I feel
dumb off scrolling so I feel it that's a
good idea for another show I'd like to
do a show called uh scrolling fast and
all it is is you watch it on your phone
and it just does the scrolling for you
and you can't make [__] sense of
anything if you don't watch a video see
a picture read any description it's just
and it plays whatever piece of [__] tick
tock song is popular right now it's just
scrolling and going
and you just
just colors and letters whizzing by this
is the biggest [__] show and people
watching it on TV or people like all
right let me see Netflix purchased
um
scrolling fast and uh so let's check it
out you tell your parents to watch
scrolling fast on Netflix it was
something scary that's that's totally
reasonable for it to be a show and dudes
he created it yeah [__] it all started
from doozy they made 30. oh it was kind
of most things do Skynet
um I just slowly singing this is getting
lower this is uh this is nice this is
fragrant lemon lemon there it is it's
really good do you have preferences on
the Ouija you like I I when I go into
the dispensary I'm like I do need
something that's like hey something
laughing and social but if I smoke a
straight straight sativa is this a
straight sativa no no it's a hybrid
hybrid that's what I smoke so if I do a
straight sativa I'll like hike for three
hours like I can't I'm one of those
clean the kitchen guys although my
kitchen could use some organizing um
I uh yeah I'll if I if I smoke a sativa
then I get to uh a little too peaked a
little too heady well damn I wish I
could do that I just get high at all
forms and just it's the same it all does
the same thing yeah see I have I have
buddies up up north one of my pals is
like and I don't know how he does it now
that I'm a weed smoker but he'll be like
he'll take several months or even a year
off of weed he'll literally I've seen
him be like you know like whatever oh
I'm not smoking until December and it's
like well that's five months and hang
out with other friends you know like our
Pals and in someone's backyard and we're
just like no I'm gonna be over here an
incredible incredible discipline but he
says the reason that he does it is when
he starts smoking again it's like
smoking for the first time tolerance and
he has a and he has a nice sort of
he has a kind of a new romance if you
will with uh with the weed for the first
that's cool you know like it's funny for
me because I can remember because being
36 the first few times that I smoked
weed
like listening to The Beatles and going
like I don't even remember there being a
[__] French horn in this song like
you know what I mean you're if things
get out there
anyway what about Edibles oh I can't I
can't do Edibles are first of all they
make me eat do they make you guys eat
yes
Edibles get me munchier than anything
else I know I try to avoid it's never
writing cycle too because there's any
more Edibles to get more high and then
that's right so you fall asleep and wake
them go I'm not gonna eat it he owns a
company that has amazing Edibles too
really yeah holy [__] it's like a
self-serving [__] thing oh wow that's
so cool but like so do you you guys
consume edibles
what what so what's the what's your
milligram amount like what gets you
what's a good amount for you I'm a
regular human so it's somewhere around
like 200 to 300.
at one time
yeah 200 milligrams yeah that's not a
lot what do you mean that's not a lot
that's like two chocolate bars yeah
they're like well it depends because
we're in the weed industry so we do a
lot of weed I do reviews and [__]
so like a couple thousand milligrams
wait a minute
you can eat a couple thousand milligrams
in one like one uh like a night or an
evening no like if I'm doing for a video
like I did three thousand to five
thousand
um I blacked out though off of Edibles
before dude I can't do more than 10
milligrams that's just different in my
body because I've been smoking for so
long yeah my tolerance is so high
but but like you know like
um you know like on the on Joey Diaz's
old podcast awesome stars of death yeah
I thought they were 2 000 milligrams
each they're 500 right or 125 or
something I thought there were thousands
oh okay that's why the whole time he is
he's eating thousands and still
podcasting I I I just saw the that clip
on YouTube and then I sunk deeper yeah I
was just like more Joey Diaz eating
Edibles please I was just extremely
satisfying and he's like it's it was
hilarious to watch because it's because
I just for me I'm like oh 10 milligrams
that's you know I go to sleep thinking I
might die tonight you know like I'm so
jealous of that maybe I'm saying that
and he's like I watch this [__] sucker
another one like you know and I just
remember this one
uh I don't know the name of the the his
uh other fella on the podcast Lee yeah
he was doing is this the guy that he
made eat so many of them that he was
turns the mush yeah it's the it was like
dude it's one of those moments where I'm
like the internet is the funniest thing
like you couldn't get I've seen you guys
move on we've watched all the movies and
seen all the TV shows there's nothing
like what it's two grown men in a
[__] podcast Studio eating these
things like Jolly Ranchers just num num
and and this guy's over here and I just
remember the part I remember is they
were talking about I think they were
talking about their favorite sandwich or
something and he's like uh chicken
parmesan sandwiches and his eyes are
like two red holes and he's like
and just sweating profusely like this is
the funniest or or you guys know who
this is do you guys know do you guys
watch on YouTube that dude customgrow420
oh yeah I've seen him before that is
some of the fun see now I haven't seen a
lot of your stuff so I'm sure I'm
probably I'm bringing up [__] that bites
your [__] I'm not trying to do no no he
stuff he made stuff before before we did
oh okay but like for YouTube [__] like
my first video we rolled like a 40 gram
joint and I smoked it without getting up
no moving no nothing just camera it was
the worst thing I ever did but I did it
as in like a yeah no you didn't like no
I think it did it's just like a
challenge videos is the kind of thing
which we do well I don't even know what
a 40 gram is like that probably it's
like that long and that like that man
and it's like what like that
okay that was a lot it was a lot I will
say yeah 40 grams it was a big joint
yeah that's crazy I just saying it's a
lot but also like we do weed stuff so
like 4 000 milligram challenge or like
two gram dabs or like uh
yes Edward Scissorhands dizzy hand
remember when people used to do uh duct
tape 40s with their hands duct tape what
40 ounces to their hands and drink of
those college kids remember that in the
90s do you remember that so I do like
gram vape pens or something no no
that's fingers no as like tapes
that is such a like a that's such a like
like automatic pavlovian kind of
response because it's like that's like
hold that would be like for me like I'm
just going to uh uh hold you know this
potato chip yeah and I'm not gonna eat
it what no and my hand I've duct taped
to or just like a weird sort of holder
that you can just perfectly is size for
like McDonald's cheeseburgers you know
what I mean it's been a while honestly
but if but right now because I've had
like three [__] toots of uh weed I'm
thinking about oh there's just a perfect
amount of [__] onions that aren't
onions
exactly the chunks of potato flavored
like onions hey
the apple pie the McDonald's apple pie
that the chunks of Apple are potato
is it it's just potato oh because
because they last longer than Apples you
put Apple flavoring on it it might be
it's probably treated with a bunch of
chemicals and [__] yeah anyway I would
love one right now and uh if it was in
my hand who the [__] doesn't go there's
a thing in my [__] hand I'm eating
that and you've got so you're like you
see like hey and let me tell you another
thing about and it's right there you
have to smoke it well it's a challenge
the challenge is like to kill until
they're gone as fast as I can
but vape pens are those are dangerous
because that's a different kind of high
oh to me that's the I get the highest
off Vape yeah I don't like the feeling
off of doing two grams worth I feel like
I'm just dizzy and high and I don't like
that I'd rather smoke a joint again yeah
I I can't do uh I can't do I can't do
pens I cannot do pens they get me into
another different feeling yeah I think I
get into a very different headspace it's
like
yeah just extremely confused I guess I
would describe it extremely confused
yeah like Beyond paranoid to like like
not understanding yeah it's not fun
sometimes yeah no I had to take a break
during one of the episodes it was just
too much for me and I've never said that
off the week dude I can't believe how
much how many milligrams when you're
like oh I don't really do that much like
400 and I'm like uh well I forgot the
measurement what 100 is that so that's
like half a tin
um it's just different different we've
been doing for so long yeah man it's
really what it is that's a lot but uh I
will say
thank you so much for being here we
ranted and ramble which is the most fun
thank you so much for having me when you
guys reached out I was stoked I'd heard
about the show but I'd yet to uh to
check it out so I have since checked it
out and I think what you guys are doing
here is great and the fact that they're
that you're this steeped of course in
weed culture with you with what you guys
do for a living and stuff it's really
cool to have this kind of
space doozy makes us smoke weed every
now and then it'll say it oh yeah we I
also
um we have a last we have a like our
little patreon thing at the end of dudes
he's called doozy after doozy and so I I
always smoke a little something from my
Gandalf pipe and and uh during dudes
after doozy you know the lighting shifts
and it's a cool it's a chill hang and
but uh on our patreon this just came out
as we're recording it today because it
is Hulk Hogan's 70th birthday today
today
70 years old The holster so we watched
um we watched 1993's that Mr Nanny that
movie oh yeah starring Hulk Hogan
um which I had never seen even though
I'm the biggest Hulk Hogan fan oh so I
was a kid because well no because I I
don't like wrestlers in movies I'm I'm
what they call a wrestling purists so
I'm like I'm really interested yeah I'm
like great Hulk you're in a movie I
don't want to pop this Cafe bubble that
I have so uh it dudes he had us watch
um watch it as a watch along reaction
thing and you watch the movie and the
thing and we got super duper stoned and
then by the middle of it I'm going he's
got his hair electrocuted out and so I'm
like hey check it out dude I'm Dragon
Ball Z brother Dragon Ball Z dude so we
just said Dragon Ball Z a bunch of times
my point is this I've never smoked weed
on someone else's podcast oh so thank
you very much so I was wondering I felt
comfortable and it's nice you guys are
great dude and so I smoked a bit of weed
appreciate that cheers thank you cheers
or something he has some scary when I
was on mushrooms he has a little
all right
oh that's uh it was too much it wasn't
it scared Josh a little child he started
rubbing his ears remember
and then he started and he had the
cowboy jacket with the Freights dude
that's crazy
uh everybody can find you at Will Sasso
correct yeah at Will Sasso on uh
Instagram mostly because my Twitter got
hacked and uh yeah it is no longer and
dudes at dudesypod show on the Instagram
also and all that stuff YouTube
everything oh yeah just doozy on YouTube
and uh yeah come check it out it's weird
as [__]
that's great
d-u-d-e-s-y dudesy we'll pop it up on
the screen also yeah thank you guys it's
one of the best slogans of all time
it's some weird [__] yeah
how about this how about you hit your
ball farther than ours and we'll go back
and you watch a precious hockey game I
say that to her often out of the middle
of nowhere oh that's amazing because
it's just funny
yeah it's just the house is over four
yards away all right sorry guys I had to
get it out I've been thinking of the
whole time thank you so much for being
here thanks for having me thank you
cheers thank you very much guys this has
been the dope as usual podcast the Will
Sasso episode from Marty will and I have
a dope ass day perfect
the battery's dead
[Music]